also mir gehen jetzt nur den bogen von
einem unsichtbaren skelett das ist sehr
kritisch also da läuft einfach geraten
bogen um fallen freuen und herzlich
willkommen zu einer minecraft folge
heute mal am mittwoch ich habe es
einfach verpennt weil gestern am
dienstag geht's eigentlich immer so
effekt tag dingsbums allerdings war
gestern der 31 und ich war besoffen und
da hättet ihr das nicht gewollt und ich
hab's doch einfach grundsätzlich
vergessen deswegen hoffe ich dass sie
mir nicht allzu böse seid das heute dann
am mittwoch mal die folge kommt das ist
ja mal ein bisschen doof der kontakt war
auch schon ein tag verschoben also diese
woche ist irgendwie so weil sie nicht
irgendwie so eine andere zeitzone und
der ist gerade lebe ja die sache ist
jetzt jedenfalls sie dass ich jetzt
einfach das video starten möchte direkt
hier damit schnell geht weil ich noch
vor produzieren muss für hamburg weil
ich ja vom 2 es wird in hamburg bin und
da muss dann jeden tag zwei videos
kommen da raus und das muss ich fahr
produzieren deswegen würde ich sagen wir
fangen direkt an mit dem ersten vers der
mir zu gesendet wurde von lukas neumann
meine emailadresse com kraft hat
gmail.com an die mir ihr an die
irgendwie effekt senden könnte und zwar
meinte er dass ich jetzt einfach mal
erde hin gras pop soul und nochmal erde
warum zweimal er alle ganz einfach hier
kann ich ganz normal weiter dran setzen
auch wenn ich dann noch einen
draufsetzen kann ich anderen reiter
dransetzen setzen habe ich ihr den
grasbrook packt den darauf auch so
erstmal frohes neues euch allen
also kann ich auch leitern dran setzen
kann ich auch ganz normal hochklettern
überall da wo leid haben sind kann ich
auch die leiter hochklettern
hier kann ich auch leitern ansätzen an
zorn ist klar weil der halt keine
richtige verbindung darstellt pool genau
das gleiche portion kann ich auch nicht
dran setzen kann ich auch hochlaufen et
cetera und jetzt hier natürlich kann ich
auch eine leiter dran setzen wenn nicht
allerdings dies ist nun so sehe dieses
gras also was heißt sehen so sehen also
nicht dieses sehen so mit den augen
sondern so ihr wisst was ich meine
dann fällt die leute halt runter das ist
genau das gleiche wenn ich hier
allgemein das sehen würde oder so
land wirtschaftlich bearbeiten würde und
dann eine leiter der versuche daran zu
machen geht das halt nicht also man kann
an allen blöcken leitern dran machen
dann den zeit auch normal ist also in
allen kompletten blöcken außer halt so
an diesen geräten oder ich es gibt
bestimmt noch andere blogger nimmer
keine realen glas zum beispiel kann ich
auch keine drei tage dran machen aber
dieser effekt gesagt hat einfach dass
ich dann alle ersten blöcke dran leitern
dran machen kann nur wenn die erde gesät
ist was eigentlich keinen unterschied
darstellen sollte kann ich dann halt
auch keine leiter dann packen ganz
einfach weil der block weil der block
dann durch das sehen glaube ich kleiner
wird oder er wird ein stückchen kleiner
deswegen kann die leiter nicht anpassen
oder wenn wir das mal so sehen würde die
leiter dann darüber hinausgehen das
perfekte wo ein spac nummer zwei und
zwar ich freu mich jetzt mal ganz
normalen zombie der steht jetzt einfach
so rum und zwar wenn ich nun sprint und
das machen ja die meisten wenn sie auf
dem mob irgendwie zu laufen auf dem feld
nicht mal pro land friedlichen hört man
auto und wenn man wenn ich den dann
schlage hört man halt automatisch auf zu
sprinten das ist egal womit ich den
schlag ich kann ja dann einfach so
weiterlaufen wie bewegt immer ein
bisschen während die märkte in die mitte
bitte billige titel täter den wachmann
sonst 9a die zombie also ich laufe
schlagen und ich bin direkt langsam ich
drück hier nix irgendwie kann es ja auch
immer selbst testen
ich kann das mit allen möglichen sachen
machen die es im spiel gibt hiermit
allen ich kann blocken hand nimmt und
ich habe halt direct wie auch zu
sprinten und ja das wäre dann frei und
ich natürlich hier die jetzt so freunde
kommen wir zum dritten akt und zwar der
zweite effekt unter dritte fällt jetzt
wurde mir zugesendet von tanja dann kann
dich und die auch ein frohes neues jahr
das hat sie mir nämlich auch gewünscht
und zwar hat die hat die tamilen den
dritten fact geschrieben weil man sieht
nur den bogen von einem unsichtbaren
skelett bei einem unsichtbaren ändern
wenn sie sieht man nur seine augen und
dem block der in einer hand hält und bei
einer pilz sieht man wenn die unsichtbar
sind halt nur die pilze am rücken ich
habe das jetzt einfach mal so aufgebaut
also auch ich habe ja mit vorbereitet
die bahnfahrt eviag also wir sehen jetzt
nur den bogen von einem unsichtbaren
skript das ist sehr kritisch
datenbogen rum dann haben wir den ändern
und wir sehen vom endermann quasi jetzt
nur die augen und dem block in einer
hand hält er hält aber gerade kein blog
in hand und beinahe pilz gesehen wir
halt bei der pilz gut nur die pilze am
rücken also alles richtig das perfekt
nummer drei und jetzt können wir zum fun
fact der fun fact dies mass effect die
mit sicherheit schon sehr viele leute
von euch kennen und zwar fallen items
verlangsamt durch spinnen weben und ich
zeige euch das mal ganz kurz mit ein
paar alten zu den schmalz darin den dar
ein glas kommt mal daran da konnten die
schwerter ein da du und sogar ein
spinnweben feld verlangen einen
spinnenweben ding fällt durch einen
spinnenweben teil und sogar verlangsamt
also die ganzen sachen fallen jetzt hier
mehr oder weniger eigentlich gleich
schnell zusammen durch die hübschen da
man das ein bisschen rum und das witzige
ist also ich im creative nordkanal
einfach so durch fliegen hier in dem
netz mal ein schwert wenn ich allerdings
aus dem gamer wieder rausgehen weil ich
dann auch verlangsamt durch mit der
gleichen geschwindigkeit wie diese
bilden items da drin
juhu ja meine lieben freunde defekt kann
dir wahrscheinlich schon ich wollte erst
ein fun fact nehmen der euch direkt
neben nbc dorfs brown allerdings wäre
dass mir ein bier speed review
musikvideo gewesen deswegen auch jetzt
das genommen in der hoffnung dass es
eventuell einige noch nicht kannten und
meine lieben freund ich würde sagen
entschuldigung dass es jetzt erst
gekommen ist also jetzt erst heute und
nicht gestern und ich war trotzdem sagen
wenn es euch gefallen hat dass eine
bewertung da wenn es euch gefallen hat
positiv wenn es euch nicht gefallen hat
negativeffekt könnt ihr mir ein
konkreter gmail.com schreiben und dann
bin ich sagen meine liebe freunde ich
hoffe er hat einen guten rutsch ihr und
eure familie und eure ganzen freunde und
ja ins tal kann man facebook ist in der
beschreibung und wir sehen uns dann
wieder wenn ihr wieder ein video
informel anklickt